so I want to talk about Harriet Tubman
and the promise that the Treasury
Department made a few years ago before
the Obama administration went out they
made the promise that she was going to
be on the $20 bill by 2020 yesterday
Steve Newton secretary of the Treasury
basically punted down the field at least
six years saying that if it happens it's
only going to happen in 2026 and it's
not gonna be anything that he will have
responsibility for take a listen in to
this clip do you support Harriet Tubman
being on the $20 bill I've made no
decision as it relates to that and that
decision won't be made in it as I said
there was a sex there was a national
there was a community process again it's
a decision of the secretary of the
Treasury right now my decision is
focused on security features and what
about imagery what about the
representation again it's not a decision
that is likely to come until way past my
term even if I serve the second term for
the president so I am not focused on
that at the moment now I'm laughing I'm
laughing because Steve Newton said I'm
not getting it to this because obviously
conservatives would lose their mind I
I'm Paul's let me say this I have to
operate in two channels at all time two
wavelengths at all time because I really
don't care if if Harriet Tubman is on
the $20 bill I don't think Harriet
Tubman would even want to be on the $20
bill of a nation in which she was
formally sold right using that same
currency or the you know the the
ancestry currency whatever I don't care
but the point is Harriet Tubman would
not want to be a part of this American
capitalistic system right she was a
product of it I believe that she would
look at this and say you know to me with
her with a very stern look and say yeah
I lost your damn minds
so me personally I didn't I never cared
for the idea and and then the the other
wavelength that I have to operate in is
like okay I get it
representation 100% matters and I only
say it I only say it like that kind of
you know with a solemn
all because you know it does matter like
you know the more images my daughter
gets to see of black women doing things
the more it makes her proud to be black
the more she she sees women doing great
things the more she believes that she
can do it like I'm literally seeing that
happen before my eyes I don't know if
any of you have children but
representation matters and for so many
of you you never had that problem
because you know all you ever saw on
television most people who look like you
will that's not always been the case for
black people so I'm I have this like
this fight waring in my mind at any
given time with most issues because
honestly who the hell cares I mean
American capitalism is one of the number
one problems that we have across this
globe and you think Harriet Tubman the
woman who set so many slaves free and
would have set even more free if they
knew they were slaves you think she
gives a damn about being on the $20 bill
I think she would be repulsed by the
idea I think she would be more
interested in challenging America a
challenging American imperialism
presently right if we moved her up to
date she wouldn't argue about a $20 bill
she would argue over American
imperialism she would argue over
American capitalism and how it's still
exploiting people across the globe still
getting essentially slave labor just by
another name that's what she would care
about but at the same time my little
girl definitely needs to see some
representation so I I have both these
these things it's dichotomy in my brain
going at any given time so there's good
about this there's bad about this but
what I love about this minuchin said I
am NOT putting myself in the middle of
this fight which he knows conservatives
will lose their mind conservatives would
absolutely I mean I wish I could cuts on
this program come to my podcast and I
was just say it the way I want to say it
but they would go back crazy over the
fact of us replacing Andrew Jackson on
the $20 bill I believe is Andrew Jackson
right one of the most evil I mean
destructive belligerent drunk
in blood thirsty monsters in American
history for whom Donald Trump is a big
fan right
of whom Donald Trump is a big fan they
would lose their mind of us take it for
us because if we rather take him off of
the $20 bill and put Harriet Tubman and
so Steve minuchin said you know what the
hell with that I'm kicking I'm putting
this down I'm putting this down the
feeling no matter how many times
represented Ayana Presley who I I know
how many times she asked him differently
he said nope he said look even if I'm
here for a second term I'm not touching
it
you know what I don't blame him